er ist einer von ihnen der kapstädter
kaya mit einer der bis an den
unbekannten afrikanischen künstler die
langsam von der internationalen
kunstwelt entdeckt werden
doch trotz erfolg möchte wird bei als
künstler weiterhin authentisch bleiben
und sich seinen themen menschenrechte
und meinungsfreiheit widmen
wir wollen geschichten erzählen wieder
an uns uns nicht einfach nur gut
verkaufen wollen
die kunst muss immer in bewegung bleiben
und muss leben david bösch bilder werden
heute für bis zu 10.000 franken verkauft
der show must go on heißt ein werk von
ihm auf der kunstmesse kam statt
ein millionär in t shirt jochen zeitz
ist industrieller mit 10 und
bedeutendster sammler zeitgenössischer
afrikanischer kunst die man noch viel zu
wenig kennt was afrikanische kunst ist
auch mal zu verändern
kürzlich hat sogar eine art james bibel
geschrieben schnitzkunst aus afrika und
da muss ich natürlich schmunzeln afrika
und afrikanische künstler haben sehr
viel zu bieten gerade was
zeitgenössische kunst anbelangt und ich
fand dass es an der zeit war den
wirklichen zuhause zu geben
hier nämlich in diesem cup starter
getreidespeicher von 1920 soll ein
museum mit weltruf entstehen
mitfinanziert von jochen zeitz
dieses soll afrikanische kunst
international sichtbar machen und ist
als non-profit-unternehmen auch als ort
der bildung gedacht eine
herzensangelegenheit von jochen zeitz
die faszination für afrika die vielfalt
drückt sich in der kunst aussieht der
künstlerische aspekt für mich und jetzt
der kunstsammlung aufzubauen kam viel
später aber die faszination für den
kontinent für die menschen für die
historie für für die natur für die
kreativität hat für mich beruflich aber
privaten wie immer wichtigere rolle
gespielt
daraus eine kollektion und museum zu
machen das ist jetzt eine idee die erst
zehn jahre alt ist und die aber für mich
logische konsequenz meine konsequenz
meines afrika wie rüstet die mich damals
gepackt hat auch geboten
ein q fell von die vermutung burg eine
anspielung auf kühe als brautpreis
afrikanische künstler sind oft politisch
und gesellschaftskritisch nehmen
einflüsse der streetart aufspielen mit
den unterschiedlichsten medien
die kunstmesse in kapstadt die es seit
2013 gibt ist für sie eine wichtige
plattform
einige der künstler hier sind bereits
auf dem weg internationale shooting
stars zu werden
jochen zeitz entdeckt eines der werke
von ibrahima hammer einem ghanaischen
künstler sehen sie auf den händen
tätowierung und und es ist so dass eben
auf diesen plantagen oftmals frauen
arbeiten die gar keinen pass haben und
der künstler und die einzige möglichkeit
zu identifizieren ist und tätowierung
ist ja eigentlich schreckte der
geschichte sich das mal vorstellen
man weiß ja dass auch in kaffeeplantagen
im bereich schokolade ist ja auch gibt
es viel kinderarbeit gibt es viele
sklaven arbeit heute noch auf der welt
und da spielt auch sicherlich auch noch
eine rolle und ich glaube der künstler
will auch versuchen klare botschaft zu
setzen
die waterfront in kapstadt symbol für
den wirtschaftlichen aufstieg südafrikas
touristenmagnet und boomendes
geschäftsviertel
hier wo auch die rasant wachsende
afrikanische mittel und oberschicht
verkehrt soll das zeit museum zu stehen
kommen als multiplikator für ein neues
afrikanische selbstbewusstsein dass
zeitz museum wird ganz afrika verändern
es ist eine verbeugung vor dem 21
jahrhundert studenten werden sie in
diesen räumlichkeiten bewegungen über
die verschiedenen arten kunst zu machen
nachdenken ein museum von diesem kaliber
wird eine enorme ausstrahlung haben
vorerst feiern hier afrikas reiche und
schöne die sich über den prosperierenden
kunstmarkt voll
doch ob der kommerzielle hype auch den
künstlern gut tut
man kennt die entwicklung aus anderen
ländern irgendwann verliert die kunst am
kraft und verkommt zur wertanlage
eine ungute entwicklung findet zaungast
marius müller westernhagen ich hoffe
dass es jetzt nicht das nächste was
abgegrast wird was war mit china erlebt
hat zum beispiel und wo ist dann
wirklich auch so eine massenproduktion
auf einmal wurde das wäre sicher nicht
wünschenswert weil genau wie wie das bei
uns im musikmarkt ist wird auch der
markt der bildenden künstler wurde immer
mehr für kommerzialisiert und ich halte
das einfach für gefährlich
noch ist nicht aller tage abend
denn die welt ist immer noch daran
afrika und seine künstler zu entdecken